[humming]
MELISSANDE: You were
gone a long time.
Yes, I stopped
to watch a bird.
A bird.
A cunning black bird.
It was going after a woodchuck.
And after, where did you go?
If you wish, I will fetch
Rene Sel down from his work
so you can ask him,
or perhaps Mari could
bring the basket
herself so you can peck
at her with your questions.
MELISSANDE: I only have
one question that matters.
Have you found a
solution to Mari?
No, not yet.
And look, we have these baskets
of well-prepared food each day.
Mari does not cross your path.
She is in the cabin, you're
here in the manor house.
It works, Melissande.
[tense music]
I will not banish her.
Your presence is
a challenge to me.
[inaudible] on the land?
I look and see smoke from her
cabin and I know she is here.
And there is no dark
magic to undo the past.
My ancestors tried, they
were burned at the stake.
I don't wish to undo the
past, just fix the present.
What if you gave her to Rene?
He has eyes for her.
I've seen it.
This is all I want for
our wedding celebration--
to know that we are
bound and there is
no woman with a claim on you.
So it is a clever fix.
Well, it is a fix.
MELISSANDE: Good.
Then talk to him.